hey daniel how are you i'm good morgan
how are you
i am great so this is so exciting
congratulations on this series and it
was really cool to see you posting about
being cast in this show
and i did not know this i don't know how
i didn't know this but it's so special
that this is your first ever tv series
lead how magical is this moment for you
it's pretty great you know uh i
understand that it's not a given for
everybody uh and you know
to to be a to be able to work as an
actor at all is a pretty privileged
place to be and to be number one on a
call sheet uh regardless of how long it
takes is
you know is something that
it's a time to look back and say hey
that's uh that's a little something
that's an achievement that that i was
i'd always hoped for and and now i get
to say that i've done and especially
with a pro a show like this
uh i i feel like um
uh i have a lot of gratitude i think
that's the that's overriding feeling
you know fans love this so much about
you but you've always been outspoken for
fighting for equality and representation
for the asian community why are you
excited about this role in particular
and what do you think that says about
representation
there are a lot of reasons i was excited
about this role um representation uh
being one of them and you know since
since that's where you're gearing the
question i'll focus on that element of
it sure yeah i'll say that you know
at the time of 9 11 at the time of the
actual attacks uh there were probably
about uh
20 20 of the fbi was made up of people
of color uh and so
uh the fact that right now in 2021 when
we're talking about who would be the
face of the fbi uh the manifestation of
the fbi that they would choose someone
who looks like me
uh says
something really positive about the
possibilities
of of
who we can play and more importantly
uh what we're saying about the fact that
anyone can anyone can play anything you
know
unless it's very specific culturally in
one way or another you know who
represents being american is
we're expanding the notions of and that
is a real sign of progress
yeah you know with this series focusing
i mean it's an intense series of course
focusing on the anthrax attacks that
happened shortly after at 9 11 causing
widespread panic do you have vivid
memories of that time
uh i do like i think most americans and
and i think a lot of canadians you know
will remember exactly where they were
when the towers fell i i remember what i
was i remember how i heard about them
and you know
both of us in north america have been
really lucky in that we've never really
had wars fought on our soil we've never
had you know terrorism to the same
degree that people in
europe and in asia
and africa as well and so
this was a time that really
changed uh
fundamentally the way that americans
spewed terrorism it was in our backyard
now
so uh it was significant for that reason
and um
you know i think
the other parallels between then and
that there are parallels between then
and now and that that is we had a
catastrophic event
and we had a country and the world unite
around that event
and and then you had polarization and
scapegoating and
and uh xenophobia as a result of all
these things and so
you know when you look at covet now and
our country's uh both of our country's
response is very different but you know
the way america dealt with uh the us
dealt with covid kind of parallels what
happened at 9 11 after 9 11 at the time
of these attacks so
there's something i think to be learned
and taken away from from that period and
i'm a big believer that you know we need
to know our history in order to move
forward with our future
uh yeah i completely completely agree
with that um it's pretty wild too that
the hot zone season one became national
geographic's most watched scripted
series ever so how does it feel
following that up
you know it's a tough fact to follow
because i saw season one two and i liked
it you know and
um but i you know it's nice to be a part
of a legacy that is a positive one and
you know i think there's a place i think
it's significant that it's not geo doing
this because their reputation for
their reputation is so stellar i
remember growing up reading the magazine
and and
to me they were always a premium brand
and i think
um what it does it actually
uh en heightens the requirements for
telling the right kind of story uh
because it's
they'll be more of an onus on being
factually based and i'll tell you that
that our producers and writers and on
the network really took a lot of care in
not exaggerating certain facts and so
uh i think i think that makes it a
positive for those who actually want to
learn something about that time as well
as be educated
absolutely and then just you know with
that said of course being so proud of
this work as well that's nice it's
something you want people to see
yeah you know and that's it's
i've been in situations where i haven't
been so proud of the projects
they've turned out and it's nice when
you actually uh do
fully
behind what you're doing yeah
okay well just to wrap things up so i
have to ask you but avatar the last
airbender you've been cast in the live
action series not just as any character
fire lord no big deal uh how special is
this for you you're the first person to
ask about that today
um yeah because we were told not to ask
but i'm doing it anyway
wait a second are you in vancouver or
toronto i'm in toronto oh okay gotcha so
you know we shot hot zone in toronto but
uh
but we
should i only bring it up because i'm
uh avatar shooting in canada as well but
vancouver um
it's a it's a lot of fun you know like
what was what was crazy about this is
when i got the offer i i i didn't
consult my grown-up friends i consulted
my friend's kids and my nieces and
nephews and i was like
do you think that i should play this
apart and every and i was like it's the
bad guy you know he's he's not a nice
guy and not a single one of them even
took time to think about it and go well
let me think it's everyone was like yes
yes you have to do this part you have to
be avatar is amazing you have to do it
yeah and so you know i was i thought to
myself like
this this will appeal to a generation of
people that i
you know don't usually appeal to because
my stuff that i usually do is very grown
up and
and more adult themed and and i just
think now that this is going to be a lot
of fun and and you know you asked about
representation before the fact that the
showrunner the producer the cast is all
asian-american representing an asian
inspired tv
show is i think really something special
yeah absolutely thank you so much for
answering that there's just i just know
i have fans who love the original series
so much so i i just know people are
really excited for this
yeah no i think it's going to be fun and
uh you know from what so far it's
looking good
yeah awesome well so nice getting to
talk to you congratulations on uh yeah
season two
right on is it getting cold in toronto
already
yes
[Laughter]
i was there from january to may last
year and it was oh
it is yeah every year canadians always
complain we're always surprised that it
winter happens we're like oh here again
but of course it is
remember we had a snowstorm on may 14th
or 15th we had
a freaking blizzard and i was like what
i know i know i was like what is that
happening but yeah all right well great
talking to you bye-bye take care
you